valve's first attempt at making a
portable gaming device is nearly here
the linux powered steam deck can be
reductively summarized as a nintendo
switch for pc gaming it's a way to take
your entire pc games library with you on
the go and it's a dramatically different
proposition to anything valve has
produced before
ahead of its initial launch in late
february 2022 we're taking a look at
everything revealed about the system so
far
the steam deck is a portable handheld pc
that will ship with valve's own steam os
built on top of linux the device is
billed as an entirely open platform
letting players install games outside of
the steam ecosystem run additional pc
software alongside them or just replace
the entire os with windows if they'd
like valve is hoping that most if not
all games will work just fine on steam
os when the steam deck launches with a
lot of work going into improving proton
a compatibility layer that allows
windows games to run on linux without
native support and without too many
issues the handheld looks like a beefier
nintendo switch with two analog sticks
and two arrays of face buttons on each
side below the thumb sticks are two
capacitive touch pads that can also be
used for directional input like the two
touch pads used on valve's discontinued
steam controller the screen is a 1200 by
807 inch display which should be great
for running games below 1080p while
maintaining crisp image quality the
steam deck features a usbc port on the
bottom for charging with valve
estimating that the device will last
between 7 and 8 hours on a single charge
depending on the game you're playing the
steam deck can also be docked and
connected to an external display for
higher resolution gaming but the
internals are very much designed for
lower resolution play 4k output is at
least supported but don't expect games
to run at that resolution internal
storage is dependent on which version of
the steam deck you have ordered but
every model also supports expansion via
microsd cards the device comes with
steamos and steam pre-installed with
support for all of steam's features such
as cloud saves messages and more
alternative game launchers such as the
epic game store or battle.net can also
be installed either on the standard
linux operating system or whichever you
choose to overwrite it with
the steam deck comes in three versions
each of which feature the same internals
just differing sizes and speeds of
storage the cheapest model only has the
emmc storage as opposed to the nvme
storage found in the two more expensive
models which you should take into
consideration giving the potentially
dramatic difference in speeds you can at
least expand the storage on each model
using the microsd card slot with storage
of varying speeds and according to early
reports micro sd cards may actually
provide comparable load times to the
internal ssd and although valve says
it's technically possible the company
doesn't suggest opening the steam deck
and replacing the stock internal storage
given how the part was designed for the
least electromagnetic interference
possible with the rest of the components
as for the rest of the specifications
that's where the steam deck really
stands apart from every other small
factor handheld pc it's the only one as
of yet that is equipped with a powerful
amd apu combining a zen 2 cpu with a
rdna 2 gpu this is the same gpu
architecture that is inside the ps5 and
the xbox series xns that isn't to say
that it will compete with those not so
portable consoles the steam deck has 8
compute units while the xbox series s
ships with 20. so expectations need to
be set accordingly but it should be more
than enough for a screen that's 1200 by
800. additionally the steam deck will
come with 16 gigs of lp ddr5 ram at 5
500 mt's a second over a 30 bit quad
channel which should be perfect for most
modern games for a while the 40 watt
hour battery is large too but overall
battery life will obviously depend on
how demanding the game is you're playing
the 60 hertz limit of the screen should
give you an indication of what frame
rates to aim for with this form factor
and some early gaming benchmarks drive
that home these benchmarks come from a
user in china who managed to get their
hands on a steam deck early so it's
entirely possible that these results
might not represent the final
performance values when the steam deck
launches this month
the most important facet of a steam deck
is compatibility with your entire steam
library something which valve can't
really confirm just yet in fact five of
the top 10 played games on steam right
now won't work with the steam deck
running steamos given the linux
operating system that underpins it the
proton layer that can run native windows
apps can do some incredible things
without much of a performance hit but
the largest issue is anti-cheat software
that so many multiplayer games utilize
valve is working hard with the proton
team and each respective software
provider to resolve this but for now
games like battlefield 2042 player
unknowns battlegrounds and more are a
no-go recently epic games did make a
change for games that use easy
anti-cheat a software solution it owns
making linux support possible without
requiring epic online services some
multiplayer games such as warhammer
vermintide 2 and dead by daylight should
therefore work on the steam deck along
with many others there are numerous
other anti-cheat solutions out there
that are integrated into many popular
multiplayer titles so it rests with
their respective developers to find a
way to support steamos natively valve is
trying to make the entire process of
determining if a game is compatible
easier with an official list of games
that the company has tested on the steam
deck the list is a work in progress and
doesn't come close to covering all of
steam but it's going to be a list that
grows over time and likely much faster
once more people get their hands on the
steam deck
by the time you get a steam deck
compatibility might not even be an issue
at all especially if you haven't secured
a pre-order yet those lucky enough to
have snagged some of the first units to
go on sale should be getting notified to
complete their order on february 25th
but any new orders won't be shipped
until much later in 2022 if this year at
all valve is using a q system that puts
the newest orders right at the back for
shipping so it might be worth waiting
for reviews to see how things shake out
if you haven't put money down yet
additionally valve is only shipping
steam decks to a limited number of
regions with no plans to offer them
outside of steam currently that means no
steam deck on amazon best buy or any
other retailer for now
the steam deck drops this month and will
be covering its launch as soon as we get
our hands on one still not sure if the
steam deck is right for you we'll check
out this breakout from the gamespot
after dark podcast where that very topic
is discussed the full episode will be
linked in the description make sure to
like this video if you found it helpful
and subscribe to gamespot for more on
steam deck i'm looking at i'm like the
more i look at it the more i'm like i
wanna i wanna try this thing i wanna see
yeah this is the thing i wanna try and
see how i'm yeah
because i'm looking at the steam deck
website and like i'm looking at the
specs too like the
uh like 16 gigabytes of ram
uh and then like the rdna 2 like it's
it's it's not the most powerful thing
obviously but it's powerful enough to
run games at 1080p
you